yeah I went hunting once shot the deer
in the leg
had to kill it with a shovel took about
an hour
why do you ask
I come from a long line of Fighters my
maternal grandfather was the toughest
guy I ever knew World War II veteran
killed 20 men then spent the rest of the
war in an Allied prison camp
my father
battled blood pressure and obesity all
his life
different kind of fight
I never really thought about death until
Princess Diana died that was the saddest
funeral ever
dad and my sisters
it's real shame about it huh yeah I must
really have you thinking about what the
older you get the bigger the chances
you're gonna die
you knew that Ed was decapitated
it's drunk as a skunk he was flying down
Route Six he slides under an 18-wheeler
pop it snaps right off
when my mother was pregnant with me they
did an ultrasound and found she was
having twins when they did another
ultrasound a few weeks later
they discovered that I had resorbed the
other fetus
do I regret this no I believe his tissue
has made me stronger I now have the
strength of a grown man and a little
baby I mean just this morning I saw a
little bird flying into the glass doors
downstairs and die and I had to keep
going how do you know what that that
bird was dead
did you check it's breathing it was
obvious was its heart beating Toby did
you check it no of course you didn't
you're not a veterinarian you don't know
anything hey Michael oh Michael oh
Michael
oh
God oh my God oh my God come on poor
little fella oh [ __ ] she's a goner no
he's not yeah no he's not Michael get
him away from your head he's covered in
germs of bacteria you can't get diseases
from a bird
[Music]
just smile for me and let the Day begin
You Are The Sunshine that lights my
heart with her when I was five my mom
told me that my fish went to the
hospital in the toilet
and they never came back so we had a
funeral for it
and I remember thinking I'm a little too
old for this
when I was five
I don't have a lot of experience with
vampires but I have hunted werewolves I
shot one once
but by the time I got to it it had
turned it back into my neighbor's dog
nobody told me we're gonna have hot dogs
hey
monkey
any problems well you left the TV on
what Deborah shotslovsky 142 South
Windsor Lane dead car accident Case
Closed please
okay
my maid died
who wants to help the world one stop up
at a time
all right good volunteerism is important
every weekend I volunteer at the local
animal shelter and they need a lot of
help down there last Sunday I had to put
down over 150 pets all by myself all
right that's Michael the custodian
called again apparently a koi has died
it's a fish they want you to pay for it
they could have died of natural causes
though well they said you stepped on its
head he did not suffer
hey how you doing I'm thinking about my
grandmother a lot
yeah she was about to turn 97. at least
she lived a very long and I'm sure very
happy life
to this card
when you're ready we all signed it we
just wanted to know we're thinking about
you the
congratulations Daryl let's get wasted
have fun today big guy
oh yeah party time whoop whoop
it's possible that some people thought
it was your birthday hooray Live It Up
Big D days like this don't come off in
enough time to celebrate
you deserve this
oh what a summer an emotional roller
coaster I ran over a turtle in the
parking lot
but then I saved him by gluing his shell
back together
but I'm not that good at puzzles ah that
piece doesn't go there
so I patched him with stuff from around
the office
but I couldn't get the pieces to fit
right then one day while I was reaching
for the glue
I crushed his shell again but I rebuilt
him even better that time but it turned
out the turtle was already dead
probably when I ran over him
but thanks for coming down Daryl
I was not thinking
you know what
I think it'd be like a Kevin Durant jump
shot perfecto
oh my God hold it
foreign
light what a ridiculous Fancy Clown you
are I am dressed according to the shrut
codes of mourning
my Aunt Shirley has died oh Dwight I'm
so sorry were you guys close I would say
that she raised me but let's not kid
each other I raised myself she was
however the closest thing I had to a
mother my actual mother was very cold
and distant I'd say she was the closest
thing I had to an aunt
all right